mais
1968 nous avait imposé le relativisme
intellectuel et moral les héritiers de
Mai 68 avait imposé l'idée que tout se
valait qu'il n'y avait donc désormais
unee différence entre le Bien et le Mal
aucune différence entre le vrai et le
faux entre le beau et le lait ils
avaient cherché à faire croire que
l'élèv valait le mettre qu'il ne fallait
pas mettre de notes pour ne pas
traumatiser les mauvais élèves et que
surtout il ne fallait pas de
classement la
victime comptait moins que le délinquant
et ils avaient chercher à faire croire
qu'il ne pouvait exister aucune
hiérarchie des valeurs d'ailleurs il y
avait plus de valeur plus de hiérarchie
ils avaient réussi il y avait plus rien
du tout et eux mêm c'était pas
grand-chose ils avaient
proclamé le mois
dernier tout s'en
allait mais 68 valait-il 40 ans plus
tard autant d'indignité la droite qui
jusque là s'était tenue silencieuse au
gré des commémorations avait-elle décidé
de laver ses querelles avec conbendit
qui avait réussi une émeute
socioc-ulturelle inégalée bien plus
intense que les grèves du Front
populaire de 36 et pourquoi ce tardif
règlement de compte à une semaine d'une
élection déjà
gagnée on a tout dit et le contraire à
propos de Mai 68 cet événement obscur
pour reprendre le mot de Sylvain Lazarus
au fond c'était une sorte de mystère de
mal français cette grosse bouffée
d'anarchie contestataire et puis coup de
canif dans le consensus signé Nicolas
Sarkozy il faut liquider l'esprit de 68
40 ans
[Musique]
après j'étais tout à fait sur une autre
planète si je dire personne n'avait rien
vu venir et et moi pas plus que
quiconque j'avais 7 ans il y a un
souvenir il y a le souvenir de pas avoir
été en classe pendant 2 jours euh ma
conscience politique était un peu
étroite sans doute mais ce8 une révolte
étudiante une grve générale celle des
ouvriers la libération des meurts j'en
garde dans mon souvenir mon père était
ouvrier et donc il en parlait en disant
que les les usines étaient bloquées donc
pour moi c'était un blocage plutôt euh
c'était une revendication finalement
ouvrière les souvenir pour moi c'était
ça c'était modification avec la présence
des médias à table ce qui est la radio
et c'était euh ma mère qui avait repris
des études qui les interrompaient et et
moi dans mon école j'étais en cours
primaire et qui était euh là aussi les
cours étaient supprimés un souvenir très
précis non pas que j'ai eu à 4 ans mais
dans les années qui ont suivi euh
d'avoir dans la famille euh de manière
générale des gens qui étaient plutôt euh
dans la catégorie de ceux qui allaient
manifester le 30 juin euh pour soutenir
le général de Gaulle sauf un l'oncle
68ard c'est-à-dire celui qui avait 18
ans
en 68 et qui lui avait été manifesté
avec les étudiants et que son père mon
grand-père avait donc été cherché au
commissariat comme il se doit moi je
vous savez j'étais boursière je venais
de me marier j'avais 24 ans
euh et comme j'étais amoureuse j'avais
échoué à mon année de de fac ce qui est
assez classique et donc ben j'avais rien
pour vivre et donc il fallait que je
travaille j'avais 19 ans pas tout à fait
20 ans puisque je suis du mois d'aût 48
je suis du 16 août 48 voilà j'avais
l'âge où on est sensible à tout ce qui
se passe autour j'avais 20 ans un peu
plus de 20 ans et j'étais journaliste
stagiaire à combat qui était le journal
bien connu de la de la résistance
j'étais à la fois actif salarié dans un
dans une administration contractuelle au
ministère de l'Industrie d'ailleurs
c'est amusant parce que j'ai ensuite
dirigé ce ministère longtemps après je
préparais l'en et et même temps jeune
parce que j'avais commencé la politique
très très jeune plutôt à l'extrême
droite à 15 ans 16 ans au moment de la
fin de la guerre d'Algérie il y avait en
moi deux faces face à ces
événements il y avait le
jeune et il y avait le fils de quelqu'un
qui avait des
responsabilités j'aimais beaucoup mon
père
évasion pour la lettre et pour la
coiffure de Guita elle encadre le visage
l'auréole de Mèch légères et délicat
allant du sable ombré au marron canelle
éclairé
d'or la France va bien elle affiche même
une santé économique à faire pasire les
experts d'aujourd'hui pas de chômage
avenir assuré
tradition emp l'ésée ai c'est vrai le
général de Gaulle a pris un coup de
vieux délaissant l'intendance il se
préoccupe du sort du monde où les gauche
toutes les gauches écoutent et apprécie
son discours c'est lui
l'anti-impérialisme l'anticolonialisme
le non aligné mais la France l'ingrat
[Musique]
s'ennuie
vous prenez la photo des des du
gouvernement des gouvernement pampidou
des ministres de l'époque des costumes
croisés de l'air compassé de la
télévision d'État de la radio
d'état les journaux à part si on excepte
quelques cas particulier minutes tout le
Canard
enchaîné il y avait un conformisme tel
qu'on avait envie de soulever le
couvercle ce qui se disait à l'époque
c'est que la France s'ennuyait la France
s'ennuie et c'est vrai que les choses
allaient bien il y avait très peu de
chômage
euh le l'économie était en plein
développement les choses all avait l'air
d'aller bien mais la société politique
elle est pas sûr d'elle parce que elle a
elle a traversé des
épreuves la montée du nazisme Munich la
défaite de 40 l'occupation et toutes ses
ambiguïtés al certes le général de
Gaulle sauve l'image de la France mais
les Français sont pas DUP ils savent
très bien que ça a été plus compliqué
que ça depuis la Libération la France
vivait dans une espèce d'oppression de
pression mais oppression pression c'est
la même chose
culturelle je veux dire par là
que les meœurs étaient bloqué c'est vrai
qu'on avait des éducations assez rigides
assez euh moi j'avais des parents qui
m'ont élevé d'une manière assez rigide
n'oubliez pas qu'on était majeur qu'à 21
ans à l'époque et les le poids des des
parents pesait très lourdement donc je
crois qu'on avait une aspiration à une
liberté dans beaucoup de domaines et et
c'est vrai que ce que j'ai lu sur les
murs de la Sorbonne ou de l'Odéon où
j'allais faire des reportages comme tout
le monde bien souvent ça correspondait à
mes aspirations personnelle et cette
société actuelle ne correspond
absolument plus aux besoins de l'avenir
et c'est cet avenir que nous qui sommes
jeunes essayons de créer essayons de
faire progresser nous ne voulons pas que
les choses restent comme elles sont
parce que comme elles sont elles ne sont
pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonnes besoin de respirer besoin de
liberté besoin de soulever le couvercle
de voir la vie en
couleur
Daniel conbendit a l'art de vous faire
aimer la révolution même s'il n'est pas
DUP lui-même c'est un gauchiste de bonne
humeur imaginatif et souvent
hilard le plus spectaculaire c'est cette
envie de parler de se défoul de vivre et
ce n'est pas une exigence réservée à la
jeunesse de gauche mon mari a passé
toute sa vie dans les prisons pour avoir
lutté contre les idées en tant
qu'intellectuel alors vous savez
seulement j'ai peur de certains excès
j'ai peur je vous dis que vous soyez
hypnotisé par des cadres idéologiques
activité journalistique je suivais des
cours de sémantique à Nanterre la fac de
nantherre et donc évidemment je je
voyais sauvageo conne badit j'étais là
au aux fameuses réunion assemblée
générale Dieu sait qu'il y en a eu des
assemblées générales à Nanterre comme
ailleurs d'ailleurs et et c'est vrai que
c'était comment vous dire on avait
vraiment un sentiment à 20 ans de d'une
espèce de de de liberté je me souviens
pas avoir passé une nuit entière au
théâtre de ldéon à à écouter ses
logoré tout était possible et on montait
sur la scène pour dire tout est
n'importe quoi le capital artistique
culturel
scientifique pas parce que c'est sur ça
que nous fondons la civilation c'est
avec ça que nous fons la Révolution la
vrai celle qui foutra pompinou et les
autres celle qui foutra l'état
impérialiste l'état militairee voulait
tout démolir tout mettre à plat et moi
je j'étais je me souviens j'étais
quasiment la seule à me à me lever au
niveau de ces ces émicycles ces amphis
qui avaient là pour dire mais mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'est-ce que
vous cherchez et puis au fil des des
débat de la pagaille à la Faculté de
droit on voit
apparaître des
personnages on les croyait les partisans
de la liberté ils
deviennent à l'évidence des
manipulateurs on voit les plus
excités demeurer sur les estrades et
surtout on se rend compte que ce souhait
cette aspiration à la liberté elle a
été capté par des gens qui
sont souvent intolérants qui ne croient
qu'en leur liberté pas la liberté des
autres au Quartier Latin ce fut la
journée la plus longue
la fête des idées des slogans des
provocations s trouvé une allié la
violence pouvait-il en être autrement
sur la ligne de fracture qui oppose
l'autorité de l'époque et cette jeunesse
altante en tout cas l'intensité de cette
violence sa spontanéité vont radicaliser
la
droite ce qui m'a frappé d'abord c'est
que confronté à la
de cette agitation et de la violence
puisquil y a eu des incidents très
graves dans la nuit du 9 du 9 au di une
série de barricades rug lac des
affrontements très graves avec la police
parisienne et cetera là j'ai senti que
les choses prenaient mauvaise tournure
voilà quelle est la part du jeu dans 68
il y a une part de jeu on peut pas dire
le contraire il y a une part de
jeu on joue à la Révolution est-ce qu'on
la croitra vraiment on joue pour
d'autres à observer voir à partir de
quelques jours avant le 30 mai la
manifestation du 30 mai la contre
révolution il y a des affrontements
assez musclés j'en ai été témoin de
quelques-uns euh c'estàd vous-même avez
participé tout à fait oui pour reprendre
science poau pour dégager les piquets de
grève c'était un peu un peu physique
virile commment dirait non moi j'avais
des copains avec
moi des copains qui s'appelaient
d'ailleurs dans les jeunes qui
s'appelaient de Bré qui s'appelaiit de
Gaulle moi je me souviens jour on s'est
fait arrêter comme ça dans un véhicule
sur le boulevard
Saint-Germain contrôle dans le véhicule
quand le flic a vu un de Bray un de
Gaulle bon il a dit circula quand il ne
s'agissait plus de jouet quand on a
senti que franchement ce mouvement
imprégner la sensibilité française dans
ses différentes composantes enfin euh
oui quelque chose se déstabilisé qui
était la France dans ces structures même
si j'avais eu 35 ans en 68 j'aurais eu
sans doute une autre réaction mais
j'avais 22 ans donc euh euh je je suis
d'une droite qui s'amuse j'aurais eu 5
ans de plus j'aurais été d'une droite
qui s'inquiète après cette cette ivresse
de la pagaille cette jouissance de la
liberté il il y a le début d'une d'une
inquiétude d'une
interrogation ça c'est pour le c'est
pour le jeune homme d'à peine plus de 20
ans et ce jeune homme quand il rentre à
la
maison
quand il croise ses
parents il voit son
père
inquiet nerveux ce père qui tout le but
de son engagement politique c'est le
redressement de la France la
résurrection du prestige international
de notre pays et qui vous dit accablé
blanc
blême tout ce travail pour en arriver
là et
donc en dehors de la maison c'est
l'ivresse et à la maison c'est une
espèce de tristesse d'abattement
d'inquiétude
d'angoisse et on sent bien ce
décalage panne
[Musique]
d'essence la France présente
uncéphadogramme
plat la furia étudiante a trouvé du
renfort chez les ouvriers chez les
salariés plus personne ne pense que le
monôme va rentrer sagement dans les FA
les lycées la France vit une crise la
France asphixie ni la droite ni la
gauche depuis la fin de la guerre
d'Algérie ne s'était penché sur l'état
mental du pays à part Edgar Morin
peut-être mais c'est un sociologue bien
solitaire le général de Gaulle est
ailleurs à l'étranger son premier
ministre ancien de Normal Sup répugne à
réprimer plus radicalement encore les
émeutes la droite s'enfonce dans le
silence c'est probablement ce vide
politique sidéral qui 40 ans plus tard
nourrit le ressentiment d'une droite
surctive ce qui
m'inquiétait l' espèce de délitement des
pouvoirs publics on sentait que tout ça
n'était pas très solide ça donnait le le
sentiment qu'il faudrait pas grandchose
pour que ça s'effondre il y avait une
sorte de vacance du pouvoir on avait
l'impression que le pouvoir était
ailleurs et que la réalité de la vie
était dans la rue moi j'ai trouvé ça moi
j'ai trouvé ça tout à fait fait
scandaleux voilà que un certain nombre
de responsables politiques ou de
ministres dont le rôle était d'incarner
l'état même si le général deg était pas
là et président et le Premier ministre
non plus qu'il n'y ait pas la réaction
qui aurait d a dû y avoir tout ça me
paraissait abérrant c'est vrai pendant
un mois personne ne réagit vous avez les
CRS d'un côté les manifestants de
l'autre ça se passe plutôt plutôt bien
il y a pas de il y a pas de
catastrophe humaine et on laisse faire
les choses on a senti d'ailleurs que
même au niveau des forces de police à la
fin il y avait un peu de flottement
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous avons
utilisé j'ai employé beaucoup de jeunes
à aller faire un peu d'intox auprès des
forces de police distribuer des des
barres de chocolat au leur dire on est
avec vous pour qu'ils sentent qu'il n'y
avait pas que des jeunes dans de l'autre
côté
mais je me rappelle d'un jour où Jacques
faukard nous a demandé si le cas échéant
nous pourrions assurer la la sécurité du
général nous-même à l'Élysée et ça vous
a inspirait quel gens répondu oui
naturellement mais nous étions un
certain nombre nous nous serions fait
tuer aucun
problème l'ordre de grve illimité lancé
par les grandes centrales syndicales a
frappé la France de paralysie de dunerk
à Marseille de Brest à Strasbourg aucun
pays occidental n'a subi un tel choc
depuis la guerre ce qui tente à
démontrer d'abord que la classe ouvrière
supporte aussi mal que la jeunesse la
grisaille du quotidien et ensuite que le
PC et sa filiale la CGT sont largement
débordés par la maladie honteuse du
communisme le gauchisme CVE crise la
France elle attendez de retrouver la vie
dans un nouveau climat de justice et de
paix et le général de Gaulle sur lequel
tout le monde compte au fond pour
interrompre la partie semble avoir perdu
son fluide radiophonique lequel je lui
demande george ségy le patron de la CGT
vole au secours du pouvoir de façon
aussi éonté qu'historiquement
ridicule on sait que la CGT a dès le
début affirmé sa solidarité avec les
étudiants en lutte vous parliez de
solidarité avec les étudiants je
voudrais connaître la position de la CGT
vis-à-vis du mouvement du 22 mars de
Bendit je pr dire Bendit qui je crois
que vous me parlez de ce mouvement qui a
été créé si récemment à grand renfort de
publicité je n'en dirai rien d'autre que
à propos de ces dernières démarches et
de ces dernières décisions que les
travailleurs voient d'un mauvais œil les
interventions qui se produisent et qui
prétendent se substituer à leur
responsabl pour diriger leur lutte la
classe ouvrière est majeure elle n'a nul
besoin d'imicion et d'ingérence
extérieure pour prendre les
responsabilités qu'elle a prendre dans
la période présente ce qui
a dans une certaine mesure empêcher que
les choses aillent trop loin c'est
lorsque les choses ont été reprises en
même par les syndicats parce que là ça a
changé ça a changé toutour on est passé
d'un mouvement
revendicatif et puis qui caractérisait
une certaine subversion on est passé
à un mouvement classique la grève
générale et cetera oui parce que quand
il y a eu la jonction avec le monde
ouvrier en fait les discussions les
accords de
Grenel ont répondu à des attentes qui
étaient les attentes des travailleurs
parce que
25 25 % d'augmentation de salaire 10 %
de réduction du temps de travail dont
les conséquences d'ailleurs étaient
assez lourdes sur le plan économique
mais cela sans doute a
orienté ce mouvement et d'ailleurs a
sans doute condamné le fait qu'il les
accords de
Grenel le monde ouvrier à son tour entre
en scène les ouvriers de Renault comme
ceux de sudaviation àante occupent les
usines cortège arrive du quartier latin
les étudiants veulent établir la
jonction avec les
ouvriers
[Musique]
l'usine restera fermée les occupants
s'opposent à l'entrée des arrivants à
l'intérieur ils veulent éviter de créer
l'occasion d'une intervention des forces
de police chacun sait aujourd'hui que le
Parti communiste et la CGT ne voulaient
à aucun prix une révolution en France on
sait pourquoi tout ça a été analysé
c'est avéré et que simplement pour des
raisons que je trouve tout à fait
respectables les syndicats ont tenté de
récupérer et le mouvement dans leur
intérêt personnel et en même temps pour
protéger la France de quelque chose qui
pourrait ressembler à une révolution
anarchique je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord maintenant là-dessus et le
Parti communiste sera le gardien de
l'ordre le Parti communiste la CGT est
un allié objectif du gaulisme dans la
dans la fin de des des des jours de mai
pour dire bon on a conclu un accord on a
signé on a gagné quelque chose
maintenant allez on rentre les uns dans
les ateliers les autres dans les bureaux
et les fils de bourgeois ils retournent
au boulot
[Musique]
les Français auront donc connu
l'étonnement parfois l'amusement ou le
défoulement et souvent l'espérance cette
fois ils sont confrontés à un drôle de
sentiment ils se sont mis à avoir peur
peur des orages portés par ce printemps
violent une peur que Charles pascoy va
savoir flairer au bon
moment nous nous sommes dit que de toute
façon face à ce qui devenait mouvement
populaire de contestation il fallait
appeler à la mobilisation populaire ce
n'était même pas un parti qui pouvait
répondre et cetera ça n'était plus de ce
niveau il fallait provoquer une réaction
populaire et c'est ainsi que nous avons
une l'idée de créer ce qui est ce qui
est devenu les comités de pour la
défense de la République et je me
rappellerai toujours d'une chose les
tris premiers qui sont venus s'inscrire
au Comité pour la défense de la
République quand ils sont rentrés il
avit pas besoin de de me dire quiils
étaient mais ils ont dit ils ont vu la
il y avait une grande une grande affiche
générale de gaaule dans la salle où nous
étions affiche du général de Gaulle pour
les présidentiels vous savez où le
général de Gaulle disait c'est vous en
62 c'est vous qui élirez le président de
la République et les trois là qui sont
rentrés il y en a un qui qui qui dit
vous acceptez n'importe qui j'ai dit oui
j'ai dit vous savez on demande pas la
religion au Pompi quand il a le feu
alors il y en a un qui dit j'aurais pas
cru qu'on se retroué une nouvelle fois
avec celui-là c'était trois anciens
officiers qui étaient plus ou moins
et
cetera ce qui est ce qui est quand même
extraordinaire et c'est sur le côté
paradoxal des Français mais ce qui assez
sympathique aussi c'est que on est passé
d'une situation
préinsurrectionnelle du 28 29 mai à la
manifestation du 30 mai et donc à 2h de
l'après-midi euh il y avait déjà euh
plus de 100000 personnes place de la
Concorde et ça a commencé à pousser
et quand le général dogol a pris la
parole c'était je crois 4h ou 4h3 alors
là euh on aurait dit que le le le les
ChampsÉlysées c'était c'était un fleuve
et que toutes les rues c'étaient des
affluents les gens arrivaient de partout
en qutité et
[Musique]
cetera le long weekend de la Pentecôte
est commencé le très beau temps et le
retour de l'essence dans les garages ont
dissipé chez les Parisiens l'inquiétude
et l'angoisse des rcents
év la victoire de la droite a donc le
parfum de l'essence des pot
d'échappement et du soulagement
bizarrement un weekend de Pentecôte au
moment où les Français prennent peur
parce qu'il a plus d'essence pour partir
en weekend alors là effectivement ça
bascule puis ça bascule politiquement
avec la manifestation du 30 mai tout
d'un coup la droite ressort les gens qui
sétai cachés qui avai
peur vont manif de la Concorde à l'AR de
Triomphe et là on s'aperçoit que
politiquement mes 68 c'est une mulle ça
fait ça fait PS comme dès ce matin les
services de la voirie ont commencé à
effacer les traces de l'émeut les
barricades édfiées la nuit dernière par
les étudiants ont été en partie
démantelé et les rues ont pu être rendu
au
piéton la parole est un fantastique
instrument politique depuis la nuit des
temps mais les étudiants cette fois ont
fini de discuter
le mois
dernier tout s'en
allait notre pays
scandalisé par l'anarchie
universitaire
paralysé par la grève
généralisée
désemparé par l'incertitude d'un
parlement sans
majorité pouvait penser que la
République
disparaissait avec la
liberté le 30 mai 100ent an qu'enfin
s'éveillait l'instinct national j'en ai
appelé au
peuple il m'a répondu dans ses
profondeurs du coup fut rompu le charme
maléfique qui nous entraînait vers
laabîe
[Musique]
la droite a relevé la
tête la gauche elle s'est pris les pieds
dans le tapis elle s'est trompée dans
son analyse et ne pourra que prendre
date pour plus tard beaucoup plus
tard de
gousé mais l'Odéon n'était pas le Palais
d'Hiver la droite respire à nouveau et
elle pense à son avenir
c'était les
prémisses du départ de De Gaulle qui
devait devenait inévitable on ne court
pas après les réformes on impose ces
réformes et donc alors que le gaulisme
c'était une volonté d'imposer sa marque
et non pas de se laisser imposer sa
marque là ils avaient été mauvais
puisque ils avaient été dominés par les
événements d'abord on s'est rendu compte
que général de Gaul était vieux qu'il
n'était pas incontournable que le vrai
patron c'était pompidau qu'il y avait
une nouvelle génération qui apparaissait
y compris Chirac d'ailleurs on parlait
peu mais on voyait bien une nouvelle
génération et dans la reprise en main
Charles pascoy et dans la reprise en
main par la droite il y a une
réunification de toutes les droites je
dirais que
l'antigolisme devient
[Musique]
caduc la machine infernale de M68 est
maîtrisée après la dissolution de la bl
décidé par De Gaulle c'est Pompidou qui
est à la
manœuvre la politique à droite et à
gauche semble avoir repris son allure
d'ENT temps on est passé tout près de la
rupture peut-être tout près de la guerre
civile personne n'est pressé d'analyser
ses échecs pour l'instant on négocie
c'est
Grenel c'est le caractère
extraordinairement sérieux de la crise
actuelle qui seul a permis d'aboutir à
des concessions aussi importantes à
travers ce que j'ai vu de de mon père du
général de Gaulle
euh de ceux qui était au
pouvoir il m'a semblé que 68 c'était un
décalage fantastique
entre ceux qui étaient au pouvoir et qui
avaient des responsabilités et qui
avaient une action totalement loouable
de redressement de la France et
l'aspiration d'un certain nombre euh de
de personne aspiration à la liberté moi
je suis très détendu vis-à-vis de de 68
j'en garde les éléments de vitalité et
de de jeux j'enarde la leçon de de la
fragilité de l'état des systèmes public
et dans les deux sens d'ailleurs j'en
garde aussi la la fragilité des foules
parce que on a à la fois les foules de
manifestants et puis quand on vote on a
ce ce résultat ce ras de Maré bleu ce r
de Maré républicain qui était simplement
totalement imprévisible oui c'est c'est
un peu l'échec des politiques qu'il soit
de droite ou de gauche à anticiper le
mouvement de société et sans doute le
pouvoir Gauliste n'avait-il rien vu
venir mais parallèlement l'échec de
Charles ETTI l'échec de mandz France
l'échec de François mitteran à
comprendre ses
aspirations était spectaculaire c'est
donc pas le monopole de la famille
politique qui était au pouvoir à ce
moment-là donc ça c'est un c'est un
signal est-ce qu'il y a des leçons ou
des évolutions sans doute une grande
vigilance oui à avoir quand il y a un
mouvement un mouvement dont les jeunes
sont à
[Musique]
l'origine on fumait des Gauloises
bleues les beau
[Musique]
jour en fuma des coloises bleu
que la droite le veille ou non la
société française va se modifier
radicalement dans les années à venir
l'école la jeunesse la famille les
comportements les désirs les loisirs la
liberté
d'expression avant si voulez c'était
chiant et après c'était
drôle j'avais connu j'avais connurepo où
il y avait des
barricades mais en face il y avait les
Allemands c'était pas tout à fait la
même chose éta accessible on pouvait
tout dire euh il n avait plus de sujet
tabou
euh et et cette jouissance de croire
qu'enfin tout est possible pour arriver
à l'égalité à la fraternité qu'il n'y a
plus de différence entre entre les uns
et les autres qu'il y a plus de misère
qu'il a plus de pauvreté qu' y a plus de
enfin ce
monde merveilleux que l'on attend que
l'on espère et auquel on croit d'autant
plus qu'on est jeune j'ai plutôt perçu
ce momentl comme étant une espèce de de
crise de la bourgeoisie de jeune qui
était plutôt qui avait plutôt de la
chance alors que moi je me battais pour
pour survivre je retiens ça de 68 la
liberté la liberté de penser la liberté
de dire la liberté d'agir la liberté de
ne pas être d'accord avec le courant
général le mainstream comme on dit
maintenant pour faire chic le çaàdire le
panurgisme on avance avec les moutons
non il y a des moments où il faut savoir
dire les moutons ils vont pas forcément
dans le bon sens et même généralement
dans le mauvais mais 68 c'est d'une
certaine façon même si les idées sont
totalement confuses et totalement
désordonnées c'est le retour en force
des idées c'est le retour de la parole
au début était le Verbe au début était
la parole des mots pas d'action
dirais-je
[Musique]
au bout du compte personne pas même le
premier des Français n'échappera à cette
sauvage liberté individuelle qui va se
développer sur la champignonnière de ma
68 avec le bon et avec moins
[Musique]
bon mais pour la droite traditionnelle
40 ans plus tard l'addition reste tout
de même très lourde trop
[Musique]
lourde on a oublié que finalement
les enfants vont à l'école pour
apprendre et pas pour faire n'importe
quoi on a considéré que les les
instituteurs les profs devent être les
camarades des gens qu'ils étaient
chargés d'instruire et tout ça a eu des
résultats déplorable en voulant abattre
les murs on a abattu tout ce qui
faisait la hiérarchie d'une société
l'organisation d'une société et
l'université reste aujourd'hui un
immense foutoire qui est la traduction
de 68 ben on conteste l'État et
l'autorité donc bah en gros on explique
que tout se vaut l'adulte l'enfant que
tout le monde a sa part de raison qu'on
doit pouvoir en discuter bon après tout
quand on s'est présenté comme ça
pourquoi pas c'est aussi la famille
cette idée que la notion d'autorité
parentale a-t-elle encore du sens
qu'est-ce qui ressort de la près mai 68
il y a eu une forte législation
concernant la
famille l'autorité parentale conjointe
il n'y a plus de chef de famille
1970 la majorité a 18 ans nous sommes en
74 il y a l'adultère n'est plus une
faute
pénale ensuite vous avez l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse vous avez
l'égalité entre les enfants les enfants
légitimes les enfants naturels donc
toutes ces avancées de nature de justice
c'est on met des cadres là où il y en
avait pas finalement ils ont dit
élection piège à con mais non l'élection
c'est pas un piége à Conon moi qui
m'occupe des droits de l'homme qui voit
partout dans le monde ces millions de
gens qui se battent pour les élections
pour avoir le droit d'élire leurs
représentant euh qui meurent pour cela
non c'est pas des cons cel c'est des
héros 68 c'est une fantastique prise de
conscience de nos concitoyens
euh pour que ils soi entendu ils soi
compris et qu'ils a le sentiment que le
message l'appel qu'il lance remonte
jusqu'au
sommet que l'on sache il y a à peu près
autant de femmes de gauche que de droite
dans ce pays alors ce sont-elles libéré
et à quel prix y a-t-il eu des excès
peut-être faut-il en accuser mes 68
moins sûr après tout le goût de vivre
irigue tout le monde le collectif tout
de même va céder la place ividu avec la
réussite personnelle communique
[Musique]
horizoné 68 alors que a priori il s
oppos ça a été le développement de la
consommation ça a été le débridement du
fric la réussite ça été le fric il y a
dans
68 la fois du collectif il y a les
communautés qui vont se former mais il y
a aussi un profond individualisme le
bonheur est en moi je suis responsable
de mon bonheur on on on n'est pas du
tout dans la logique de de l'immédiate
après-gerre du militantisme il y a une
démarche extrêmement individuelle sur
les notions d'individualisme et
d'individualité à l'évidence 68 à libéré
cela le droit de jouir sans entrave là
c'était aussi un des slogans est-ce que
pour autant ça conditionne le mode de
vieement non c'est pas ça qui c'est j'ai
pas eu traumatisme infanti ou prê
adolescent dans ce
domaine en 40 ans la France a été
principalement présidée par la droite à
la très notable exception de François
mitteran seul Nicolas Sarkozi a cru bon
de revenir sur ce sujet car ma 68 est un
boulet qui depuis qu décennies complique
la vie des partis de droite et affiche
leur supposé antimodernisme Nicolas
Sarkozi sans complexe a manifesté le
désir de se réapproprier le débat après
tout il est interdit d'interdire
le problème de savoir si la la droite si
M 68 a profité à la droite dans la
mesure elle lui aurait permis de de de
de se dé faire de ses complexes est un
vrai problème c'est un problème c'est
une question très très intéressante ça
aurait pu être ainsi ça n'a pas à mon
avis été ainsi ça na pas été en tout cas
comme ça aurait dû l'être la droite une
fois de plusraté une occasion jusqu'en
mai 68 en réalité la droite c'était
Pétin ceux qui se réclamai de droite qui
affichai voilà je suis responsables
politique de droite ont été il
s'inspirai d'une
filiation de de de de la guerre et à
partir de mes 68 il y a eu
progressivement une évolution et cela
abouti d'ailleurs à ce qui on voit ces
dernières années c'est-à-dire une
affirmation non
excessive
claire sans doute équilibré de mon point
de vue et lisible en disant qu'on peut
être de droite sans que ça soit honteux
mais à l'époque euh ça c'était moi
j'étais une femme de droite bien sûr
j'étais j'étais centre
droit c'était difficile de dire qu'on
était de droite et ça éit disqualifié
quoi oui B c'était oui c'est ça du reste
il y avait aussi dans ces discussions
parce qu'il apparaissait naturellement
que ce que je défendais étaiit des
valeurs plutôt dites de droite que que
ça n'avait pas de droit de citer que
c'était complètement archaïque que ça
n'avait absolument aucun sens ce qui est
vrai c'est qu'on a pour beaucoup d'entre
nous pendant trop longtemps pas assumé
d'être de droite alors qu'on avait en
face de nous des gens de gauche qui
commençaient par dire qu'ils étaient de
gauche ce qui les à leurs yeux valait à
soit tout seul discours politique et
crédibilité politique alors que c'était
pour tenir des discours excusez-moi d'un
autre monde et d'un autre temps le mur
de Berlin est tombé et il n'y a
plus cette espèce de qu'on avait à
l'époque cette guerre froide entre le
monde non pas de gauche le monde
communiste et le monde libéral ce qui a
changé foncièrement c'est que vous avez
en Europe des pays qui sont dirigé par
la gauche mais c'est une gauche
libérale ce sont des socio-démocrates à
l'époque c'était pas des socio-démocrate
qu'on avait en face de nous c'était des
communistes le couteau entre les
[Applaudissements]
dents la
France il était donc urgent entre les
deux tours de la campagne présidentielle
d'en finirve avec la permissivité de 68
ce goût forcené et malsin pour la
jouissance sans entrave et ce dédun des
codes à la maison au bureau à l'école et
même dans
[Musique]
l'isoloir mais voyez tous ceux qui se
réclament de l'héritage de M 68 vous les
reconnaîtrez certainement il donnent aux
autres des leçons qu'il ne s'applique
jamais à
eux-même ils veulent timposer aux autres
des comportements des règles des
sacrifices qui ne s'imposent jamais
eux-mêm voyez-les écoutez-les il
proclame toujours faites ce que je dis
ne faites surtout pas ce que je fais je
ne crois pas un instant à la sincérité
de Nicolas Sarkozi quand il a fait ça je
comprends parfaitement que Nicolas
Sarkozi a ouvert la boîte de68 pant au
dernier jour de sa campagne électorale
euh mais je relativise les choses
Nicolas Sarkozi a ouvert toutes les
boîtes mais le président de la
République avait compris une chose
d'abord c'est que pour être élu
président de la République
euh il il faut se souvenir que la la
majorité se gagne à droite
elle se gagne pas au centre comme on
nous l'a dit pendant des lustres et donc
il a mené une campagne de droite il a
donc vidé
l'électorat il a vidé le le Front
national de son électorat mais dans le
même temps il a tiré un nombre de leçons
diriez-vous que le chef de l'État par
exemple est un produit de ma 68 quelque
part dans son côté dans un certain sens
oui ce pseudoodernisme ce que j'appelle
modernisme un peu toc
oui dans un sens oui qui en le refusant
paradoxalement il en est le plus produit
moi je me réfère à son discours
d'investiture quand il dit je suis libre
j'ai changé il demande à ses amis
politiques d'ailleurs de le laisser
libre d'aller bien au-delà de son son
parti pour pouvoir rassembler tous les
Français dans le cadre d'un engagement
politique alors cette revendication de
liberté dans le
respect de de sa famille politique euh
c'est une forme d'héritage de 168 je
pense que au contraire c'est un héritier
du gaulisme qui a rendu cette fierté euh
de la France cette fierté d'être
français on pourrait penser qu'au-delà
de d'un mouvement social ou étudiant ou
de meurs on pourrait penser que c'est
aussi une attitude celle de la remise en
cause d'un ordre
établi en ce sens je pense que le
premier d'entre nous est peut-être à
68 parce que le 68ard c'est celui qui
considère que il n'y a pas d'ordre
établi il faut ouvrir les champs du
possible il avz proclamé les héritiers
de 68 que désormais tout était permis
Laue que l'autorité cétait
[Musique]
finie c'est de bon temps de faire la
logie de mes 68 n'est-ce pas parce que
euh chacun chacun rêve euh de participer
à un grand mouvement populaire de
changer profondément la société et
cetera surtout quand ça se fait sans
grand risque n'estce pas quand il s'agit
de risquer sa peau c'est une aut il y a
moins de moins de
volontaire on est resté avec cette
liberté moi moi j'associe ma 68 au mot
liberté liberté de penser liberté de
parler liberté d'écrire et j'ai gardé
cet esprit là alors dans ce sens-là je
suis peut-être un peu post 68ard pas
moi pas moi les 68ard ont eu le le droit
de vivre pleinement de jouir sans
entrave comme il
disait et nous nous n'avons que des
entraves donc nous ne jouissons pas
véritablement et et sans doute parce
que ce souffle de
liberté continue à exister pour
eux-mêmes mais moins pour
nous ils ont eu le plein emploi la
croissance économique des retraites bien
payées ils ont eu le droit de de
s'amuser il y avait pas le sida
aujourd'hui nous il y a le sida il y a
il y a
il y a la crise économique il y a on vit
encore chez Papa Maman parce qu'on a pas
les moyens on a peur de l'avenir on on
n'est pas dans l'insouciance ni dans la
légèreté notre génération qu'est-ce qui
a bougé est-ce que la justice a
progressé est-ce que l'égalité a
progressé est-ce que la liberté a
progressé absolument pas nous en sommes
à l'état 68 ce qui a progressé et ce qui
a changé ce c'est l'évolution des meœurs
que tout le monde voulait que même les
électeurs de de Nicolas Sarkozy
aujourd'hui approuvent et dont ils ont
profité et dont Nicolas Sarkozy lui-même
a profité c'est en cela qu'il est un
enfant à sa façon sans le savoir une
sorte de bâtard euh ça sait pas d'où ça
vient un bâtard c'est lui-même a profité
de mes
[Musique]
68 bien sûr lorsqu'on est jeune on aime
toujours occuper la rue une obligation
de jeunesse une sorte de most et comme
tout le monde se plaît à souligner c'est
plutôt un signe de bonne santé
[Musique]
démocratique et puis à quelques
exceptions près nos poussées de fièvre
semblent moins furieuses plus
décontracté qu'il y a 40
ans les générations passent ce qui
n'implique pas qu'elles se comprennent
davantage il y a une anecdote qui m'a
familiale qui m'a beaucoup marqué et que
m'a raconté mon mon oncle 68 art
justement un jour où il se trouve que
donc mon oncle a été embarqué au
commissariat et donc avec ses copains et
mon grand-père est allé le cherché le
lendemain matin au commissariat lui et
il l'a convoqué le mot à son sens avec
se ou h autres de ses copains il les a
fichus dans la même la même salle de
chez lui de son appartement je sais pas
d'où et il leur a dit maintenant je vous
enferme là vous écrivez sur un bout de
papier pourquoi vous êtes vous êtes 68
he pourquoi est-ce que vous faites
toutes ces revendications et mon me
raconte encore en ce Mar mais il avait
vraiment rien compris c'est penser que
ça pouvait se résumer à une copie que le
père de famille allait exigé d'avoir de
ses enfants pour qu'il disent sur papier
ce qu'il pensait était un parfaite
illustration du malentendu profond qui
existait c'est vrai que ces années- là
c'est des années où à table les gosses
il parlaient pas qu'on qu'on y avait pas
de dialogue il y avait une autorité
point et que c'était too much je suis
persuadé que c'était ça est-ce que
finalement ceux qui sont les avocats de
68 aujourd'hui n'ont pas fait la même
erreur que les GO
de l'époque c'est-à-dire pas voir que
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui attendent du
sens attendent certain esprit de
responsabilité et et et
finalement les événements de 68 leur
paraissent comme un ancien combat comme
le combat des goolistes sur la
résistance et sur ce qui s'était passé
pendant la guerre était apparu dépassé
par la génération de 70 qui espérait
autre chose donc est-ce que finalement
on n' pas simplement une évolution
générationnelle tous les 30 ans un
passage qui se fait peut-être plus
difficilement en France parce que le
système français est tellement
oligarchique tellement figé qu'une fois
qu'une génération elle pouvoir à la
tendance à le garder on leur doit
beaucoup d'un côté mais d'un autre côté
il faut qu'il nous laisse vivre il faut
que nous coupions le cordon ombilical
que nous tuions le père
et d'autant plus que le père n'est plus
le Le Libertaire d'avant il est devenu
un conservateur à bien des
égards cette génération est un peu
étriquée dans dans dans cet héritage il
a besoin aussi d'apporter sa pierre à
l'histoire comme eux l'ont
[Musique]
fait la droite n'a pas oublié l'affront
de 68 elle n'avait pas vu le coup venir
dans une France toute fière et à juste
titre de ces tres glorieuses la droite a
eu peur elle a entrevu la chute de ses
institutions aperçu le spectre de la
subversion et le visage de l'anarchie et
a vu son délitement instantané plus
jamais ça mais tout de même un autre
mai si on oublie pourquoi 6 est arrivé
ce décalage entre les responsables
politiques et le peuple si on oublie que
certains en avaient assez que les élites
captent tout et captent non seulement le
pouvoir mais la parole et bien on
retrouvera à ma 68 ne comptez pas sur
pour moi pour vous dire que ça ne se
reproduira jamais ce qui est sûr c'est
que les conditions qui avaient fait mai
68 la prospérité
élément fondamental quand tout va bien
on peut se permettre de faire la
révolution et deuxièmement une société
qui quand même était extraordinairement
bloquée ces deux conditions ne sont pas
là donc il y a aucune raison d'avoir un
nouveau mes 68 maintenant qu'il puisse y
avoir des agitations ça c'est autre
chose les mouvements de protestation moi
je trouve que c'est un signe de bonne
santé que de pouvoir protester
manifester revendiquer donc euh euh
justement euh il faut rendre grâce
d'être dans dans un pays libre
démocratique où on peut manifester
contester ne pas être d'accord et euh
c'est ça euh être libre je trouve qu'on
devrait beaucoup plus de aujourd'hui
être sur les barricade quand on voit la
la jungle de la mondialisation qui est
1000 fois plus choquante
euh aujourd'hui quand on voit qu'on a
rétabli l'esclavage dans le monde en
fait quelque part et qu'on vit de ça que
nos entreprises vivent de ça enfin ça me
paraît source de 1000 fois plus
d'indignation que ce qui s'est produit à
l'époque rien n'est incontestable même
pas mais 68 sinon c'est renié l'esprit
de cette parenthèse enchantée quand la
France s'ennuie et ben là tout est
possible il faut qu'il y ait des
objectifs il faut qu'il y ait des causes
collectives il faut qu'il y
ait des des perspective humaines et il
faut qu'il y ait des défis et
aujourd'hui on se dit peut-être que face
à aux événements que que du monde à
cette mondialisation il y a deux
attitudes où c'est la fatalité ben on
laisse faire où on
réinvestit les politiques réinvestissent
le champ de l'action
et et 68 % ça est un peu un modèle avec
ses erreurs avec avec ses utopies avec
ces manipulateurs mais c'est au nom de
l'idéologie c'est au nom d'une
libération c'est au nom d'une volonté
d'une politique faite pour l'homme
autour de l'homme autour de sa liberté
autour de son égalité dans cette
recherche de fraternité que des gens se
sont
mobilisé paradoxalement je vais vous
dire ce qui est ce qui moi ce que je
retiens de tout ça
c'est c'est la capacité pour les jeunes
de
s'enflammer même même si les idées sont
contestable
et et je pense que quand on est jeune il
faut garder il faut avoir un capital
d'indignation une capacité de
mobilisation et cetera mais il faut on
pas se tromper de combat voilà mais mais
mais Paris mais
mais
[Musique]
Paris
Paris je ne veux plus cracher dans la
gueule à papa je voudrais savoir si
l'homme a raison ou pas si je dois
endosser cette guérité droite
avec sa manche gauche avec sa manche
droite ses BES au raison ses Hynes
cramoisies sa passion du futur sa
chronique
[Musique]
amnésie le père le grandit à son petit
gars mais enfin bon s qu'est-ce qu'il y
a qu'est-ce que tu vas faire dans la rue
fiston je suis allé faire la
révolution mais bon s bon s je te donne
pourant assez d'argent la société de
consommation je peux aller faire la
révolution
la
[Musique]
Révolution
la
[Musique]
révolution